p a t r o n i z i n
g
oh yeah today I want to talk about how
you're not traumatized you're probably
just hurt there's a disturbing Trend
lately where psycho Babble and the
Zeitgeist has been distorted twisted and
sometimes even weaponized this has given
the people the idea that they can
prioritize selfish uncommunicative
behavior under the guise of self-care
misused psychological Concepts like
trauma abuse and diagnose others who
have hurt them in order to dismiss their
own pain now terms like gaslighting and
attachment and emotional labor have like
bled into the social lexicon giving
people so fact every time there's a word
that comes out there's a group of people
that take that word and run with it
toxic masculinity and they put that
thing in the
clip and went outside and
went it went Oprah on everybody you got
toxic masculinity you got toxic why you
put in a vest on you put your toxic
masculinity on that's not tox that's
toxic that's not toxic mascul no cuz
you're trying to no I if you go show up
in chill you're yelling you're yelling
that's
St no bro you can't keep just showing up
here looking like you just murdered
something in Russia and then think I'mma
just come out here in my manscaped
donated clothing okay and then we going
to be fine it out talk about and that's
and that's and that's that's I want you
to feel like your emotional labor is
recog him right now right now
interrupting me toxic masculinity you're
pushing me it's not that it's not that
it's like I'm engaging in emotional
labor and I feel like you don't
recognize the effort I'm putting in so
it's making me feel neglected and as a
result of feeling neglected there's a
part of me that's being hurt this is a
form of emotional abuse you don't
recognize it no no I'm not even joking
when someone's trying to connect with
you and you cut them off before they get
a chance that is a form that's what you
do of emotional trauma that's what you
do that's trauma that's what do you're
trying to get close to me by
traumatizing I'm just trying to make
money and explaining my [__] okay talk
about cuz I feel like it's so hard to
get you to open up you're so patronizing
right now no I feel for me it's hard to
get you to open up no you know you know
that's what you're doing right now
you're you're you're so patronizing all
the time or you try to be like this why
don't you spell patronizing uh p a t r o
n i z i n
g
oh yeah
can you not be so
hostile I said you know what you need to
start doing the next time someone says
gas out you'll spell that [__] if you
can spell it I'mma say I did it that's
what we going to do that's what we going
to
do gaslighting go ahead [__] spell it
and even if they guess right just say
they wrong gasl
them stay toxic my friends it's a evil
world we live
in yeah let's do that let's do that
let's do this the core of what humans
want m is knowing exactly and being able
to to predict and know exactly that's
why there's people that are fans of
astrology where they I know I know this
I I can I agree I remember saying that
that that that the cycle Babble is just
another form of astrology yeah I know
that I know the signs people everywhere
permission to cut out the toxic people
at the slightest hint of discomfort
conflict or disag agreement people are
literally slinging armchair diagnoses of
narcissism PTSD or sociopathy around
like they're an Oprah themed popped open
pinata right you get a diagnosis you get
a diagnosis and though this trend has
its upsides it encourages people to get
help it gives them the tools to
recognize patterns that aren't working
for them it provides language to more
accurately communicate their feelings it
also has a really uh Stark downside
which is that this blunted lens has
warped our view of relationships we're
not seeing them as nuanced and complex
dynamics that require an ongoing
dialogue but as a one-way transaction
there has been so much rhetoric online
lately that encourages disconnection
over communication or language that
insists your needs be placed Above All
Else and this kind of black and white
thinking completely ignores that we live
in a messy world and sometimes our
relationships will require compromise I
don't think you can go into any
interpersonal Dynamic expecting that
your needs are going to be met 100% of
the time that's just not realistic and
because there's so much like Instagram
therapy going around I want to clarify
my personal philosophy of what I believe
our approach should be so I think you
should put your own needs above other
people's wants but put other people's
needs over your wants I think putting
other people's needs over your own needs
is at times necessary and it's also a
very kind loving sacrifice to make
however putting your needs over other
people's needs is also sometimes
necessary and a kind loving protective
thing to do and this dance of deciding
whose needs take priority this is a
caseby casee basis that should be
balanced based on your best judgment
look boundaries are meant to keep people
in not out well that's pretty cool that
wasn't bad I like
that feel like we only posi to be like
[__] but I'm like I don't mind
that I'm still thinking about it but go
ahead if there not a need for you you
should consider your part's needs so if
she needs you to shut the [__] up but
you just want to talk then you should
shut the [__] up right but if you need
to talk and she needs you to shut the
[__] up sometimes you need to still keep
talking you know what I mean yeah yeah
same way if you if someone needs to talk
to you but you don't you don't want to
talk to them sometimes you have to talk
to them because that's your
responsibility yeah but sometimes they
really need no sometimes no sometimes
they want to talk to you they don't need
to yeah they don't need to right but
the way the way the way they say the way
they say it is no I need to talk to you
no it's it's key word is need but you
really have to exert no you really want
and there's a difference between really
want and need that's fact that's facts
why I say some people don't know the
difference between they want they need
some girl wants a man that will walk
with her on the beach every week but she
don't need that but she might say she
does I need a man who's hyper romantic
you don't need it no you don't need it
you want it you want it it's different
and you really really want it doesn't
mean you really need it okay all right
speak on that so communicate your
feelings instead of avoiding conflict
and being triggered look that's actually
a gift to see what you need to work on
not to not a way to censor other people
like yes we should all be very
considerate but if you're seeing
triggers more in terms pause pause pause
I like I like yo at some point those
words when they when they get used a lot
at some point it becomes a an insult
just like triggered I remember at some
point people was like was saying to me
yo okay you're triggered and I was like
yes no yeah yeah that [__] triggers
me eating with your mouth open triggers
the [__] out of me okay shut your
mouth yeah I'm
triggered you be triggered I'm triggered
you be triggered oh yeah absolutely 100%
AB there's some [__] that triggers you
as well no I'm composed I don't know
what you're talking about just because
I'm sweating don't mean I'm nervous just
means I'm
hot
whatever
preach chinchilla you playing it's it's
Mr chinchilla to you okay Miss preach
yes Miss preach and Miss ABA
okay if you're seeing triggers more in
terms of like censoring others rather
than an opportunity for self-exploration
you're doing yourself a huge disservice
all of these tools are meant to help us
navigate relationship Dynamics they're
meant to help us repair inevitable
ruptures they're meant to protect our
ability to remain engaged but if you're
using therapy speak as an excuse to ice
people out diagnose someone postmortem
your relationship or set rules for
another person's Behavior you are
misusing them in an attempt to justify
your own victim mentality insecurity or
ego like okay all right I don't want to
play the whole thing I think that's a
good point to stop it at but some
short-term thoughts what I would say is
this I understand the
need to self- diagnose not everyone can
afford therapy or go to figure things
out on a professional level so trying to
make sense of the pain that you feel
that's very real is difficult Y and who
is anyone on the outside to tell someone
who's hurt that they're not
traumatized very difficult you don't
know their experience you don't know
what's going on internally for example
two people can get in a car accident one
person's traumatized the other one's not
someone can look at the situation
neither of you traumatized someone else
can look at it in both of you
traumatized but the truth is only the
person who's going through it who can
explain their symptoms to a professional
actually will be able to engage with the
fact that they're
traumatized so diagnosing others to me
often times is very
unproductive I think it if you're going
to do it do it so very it's like salt
add it to the dish don't drown the
[__] people are drowning they drown in
ins
salt all of a sudden they look little
thirsty but they cause their own
suffering
yeah all I'm trying to say is in an
effort
to make sense of the world you actually
shroud it in more Darkness because by
diagnosing something with PTSD you lose
the Nuance of the situation so you don't
actually come to an understanding of why
that behavior was actually there instead
you project it onto some trauma that
happened in the past and you're saying
this is why that happened or maybe
there's a result of your own behavior
maybe it's a result of something else
that happened to that person maybe it's
a result of work stress but when you
make everything about this diagnosis you
leave at there's no room for that Nuance
to come into play I you know what
sometimes your partner wasn't a
narcissist they were just an [__] to
you and the next person they get with
they're extremely kind with them but
that happens maybe you trigger some [__]
maybe you bring out a part of him that
reminds him of his mom or his sister or
his first crush and he has unresolved
feelings or sometime it was just you or
sometimes you the shitty person and you
bring out the bad things out of people I
mean I got to say this I know some girls
who want to convince me that all their
exes were narcissists then I'm like
[__] what are you the narcissist
catcher like a dream catcher but for
narcissist is that you are you the one
who's just like like like like a rat
trap but for narcissist everybody just
falling into your [__] and you suffering
from that what what are you doing to
constantly attract narcissist if I'm to
believe the diagnos or the more likely
thing since narcissists are so rare is
that maybe that's what I'm about to say
just maybe you have a bad pattern with
who you're dating but maybe they're not
all narcissists maybe there's just
certain patterns of behavior that are
bad and a partner well narcissists are
like 5% of the population I mean even
all the 5% of the population fall in
your lab I think it's even less than
that I think it's even less I'm just
being 5% is an insanely High number yeah
but I think it's even less than that let
me look this [__] up even less than that
and people throw that [__] around like
everybody's a narcissist well I mean my
understanding of
narcissism is that we all have a certain
level of narcissism is that some people
who end up really really high on the
Spectrum are actually like
diagnosed between .5 and
1% that's not that high no it's very
very you hey [__] everybody can get a
lottery ticket your 5% landing on it
every time not everybody can be a
narcissist in your life no no so
sometime it got to be you and here's the
crazy part too this is something that
people don't know not all narcissists
are bad people not all narcissists are
[__] Partners there's plenty of
narcissists who get married have kids
and mitigate a lot of their narcissistic
Tendencies to be able to have a
functioning reality MH I'm pretty sure
that narcissism just relates to the fact
of the way your brain's wired and the
way you relate to emotions or empathy in
that regards right it doesn't
necessarily mean that you're inherently
going to act out those behaviors all the
time or you can't mitigate that oh like
the sociopath or the
psychopath this some [__] up but even
people who didd kids or people who have
that attraction yeah not most people who
have that attraction don't actually do
it no that's a kind of [__] up thing
to even think about so all this to say I
understand why people do it but you have
to recognize short and quick answers
rarely exist often times the problems or
the things that we want to solve are
complex they take time they take
reflection they take life experience
people just want to slap a label because
just like PRI said earlier it just makes
them feel comfortable and makes them
understand the world what do you want to
say nothing I want to feel like I
understand the world I know what's going
on see this is the part that frustrates
me about our Dynamic cuz I do all this
emotional labor and then pass it on to
you it's like you don't even recognize
it and I think it's okay and this is why
I feel neglected in this Dynamic it's
fine and that would be emotional
abuse a partner who doesn't acknowledge
your pain your suffering your labor
that's your pain that that's your pain
you don't see it cuz you think I'm
sweating but these are tears I just I
just I cry
from that's gas
lights you you cry from your forehead n
yo that [__] was Fu this [__]
crying like this nah B when they say
Ethiopian men are sensitive this is what
they talking about but nobody nobody
said that ever ever that's true that's
true nobody said that nobody said that
but I can't tell they are very s um
moving on from that point um me
personally when I meet a girl she starts
throwing out oh he's a narcissist or
gaslighter this and that I start rolling
my RS those are eyes not ours but I do
roll my ours you know what I mean no you
don't really
when I see a girl and she throws away
all those affirmations okay I'm fuing up
I think when she's saying the person is
narcissistic and
gaslighting I think I rolling my arms I
[__] it up I'm just say it's cring
don't do it okay roll your arms not your
eyes you know what I mean you try to go
you really try to go with
it when live gives you lemons roll yours
so that's all I got anything else you
want to say about narcissism gaslighting
nah I didn't actually
sneeze God all right
I'm